it seems like you should have been in a
movie already like did you know each
other before you've never even met we'd
never met that's so weird
well we never met everybody's gonna go
really sweet you were yeah go do it do
it yeah I know it's not romance there's
kind of the action and the drama and all
that kind of you know what you want from
big science fiction movie yeah but you
didn't mention that more than once
yeah you see me fully naked in this
movie yeah stay for the spaceship and
[__] because you've talked on here
Jennifer about when you prepare for kind
of more intimate scenes but your breath
but to be your breath so how did Chris
fare in the in the breath control well I
said when I'm whenever he had to kiss
Josh and Liam for the Hunger Games who
cares like mustard and tuna like cares
then I went off and I did the American
hustle and I was like Christian Bale and
I was like and I ate mints
I was thinking mints as in mincemeat
lovely it was corned beef Chris Pratt
you apparently like getting it and at
one point you tried to turn that into
your source of income well not for a
while I stripped for money bless you I
loved that successfully well I mean if
when you need 40 bucks and you get 40
bucks I didn't do I liked it never got
like on innocent you know what I mean
like I actually did it maybe three or
four times and then decided I was gonna
go and like audition at an actual
nightclub like a like a strip club for
men and I with male strippers you know
and I went and I did an audition but
when I was there there was like a guy
sleeping in his car waiting for the club
to open cuz he was a dancer there and I
just felt this darkness that I was like
this is about to turn this is like going
from fun funny storytelling thing but in
you know 15 years I can tell on the
Graham Norton Show - you know I could be
that guy yeah yeah anyways moved in with
the guy in his car
my manager
[Music]